each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so welcome everyone thanks for having me
so this is a joint work with Emilio
dechristoforo my former lab mate flood
may actually too much time spent
together so first of all why we working
on pepsi iced any talk we start with
motivation where there are pretty much
too first one is the algorithm an
appealing name in your paper so you pick
a cool acronym and then you make up the
words of the title and you try to
motivate your choice if you're not happy
you go to one another motivation is that
there lots of food in cryptography
actually but there were no drinks so
that's why we came up with pepsi apart
from jokes these participatory sensing
things it's a very hot topic in my
opinion so it's a very fast-growing
computing parody that deals with the
seamless collection of data from a large
number of devices and those devices are
user carry device those are your mobile
phones ok it's about harvesting dynamic
information of environmental trends
whether that this interesting or not
there are people from other departments
are looking at it but there is a big
potentials with this kind of for new
application and for new business models
there are over five billions phone users
awesome now that was BBC report 2010 and
those devices are always on always
carried and always connected and on top
of that they have a number of sensors
embedded in it you get accelerometers
you may get thermometers and the basic
idea is that people might be actually
more interesting than modes the
information they carry and the
information that they collect from their
environment from the everyday life may
be actually more interesting that adult
gadget as a sensor that sits in the
ground or in some piece of concrete out
there there are lots of project going on
and there are lots of so where you have
this mobile phone and data gets
connected continuously from all the
sensors in the phone and when you say
participations anything does use it how
to explicitly do something on it or is
it running in the background collecting
yard you're basically including both the
kind of paradigms or only one side
that's a good point actually there are
two different flavor of this particular
participatory sensing one of these
seamless to the users transparent
reduces that is discontinuing sensing
that basically is the phone that is
continuous gathering data about the
environment and there are other flavors
other fashions of the spotting we're
actually user have to do something right
for example that is there is a project
nice good at this web page sensor planet
that is shading consumer pricing in
offline market okay so here basically
user have to do something to provide
information to the system for example I
can provide the price of the goods where
I go shopping so if somebody else is
looking for the same goods the knife
that I had looked for he can just take a
picture of the barcode and send this
picture to as long as long with its
location to the system and the system
will tell him if there are other shops
in the area around in the surrounding
area that sell the same good at a
cheaper price okay so this is not
seamless this is something where the
user has actually to participate but you
know we also target the seamless
collection of data but in both cases
there is human action involved or at
least resources of the computing device
right so you have to spend some battery
and some computational resources of your
mobile phone or any sensing device that
you carry which
you so the real question is whether you
want to do it or not okay so that's the
real gist of the problem if what you get
back from that right okay so the number
of project is pretty big and it's
growing so we have web page where we
have trying to we're trying to collect
all these projects but the the factory
top the whole the topic is alt is
supported by the people who are working
on it so we have Stanford we are
Berkeley we have UCLA we are in 10 we
have no cure so everybody is looking at
this new applications because there's a
huge potential there okay so the first
question is well it is actually a new
computing power is just W sin well we
have some differences first of all of
course w cents are very source the
sensors that we see in regular wsn are
very resource constraint devices he is
not the case because here we have very
fancy smartphones with lots of battery
the battery can be recharged computing
power is not a problem memory might not
be a problem but the real different is
the one here at the bottom so far in wsn
the owner or and the network manager of
the network was actually the one
quitting the sensors so for example the
the National Traffic Authority embedding
sensors in the concrete of the streets
and querying for the standards of the
concrete okay so there's no real privacy
issue here in participatory sensing
users are providing data that is
gathered by their mobile phone about
their surrounding to other people so
here the mayor there are actually
different entities that coexist and
might not trust each other so here we do
have a privacy problem so this is the
big picture that's your mobile phone and
use the crowd that may be interested in
your data the peculiarities of this
system is that the data producer and did
consumers have no moral knowledge they
don't know each other they never met so
we actually do meet somebody in the
middle a service provider or a broker as
you may like so that means that data
producers will produce data without
knowing whether and who will eventually
look for this data so i can send from my
mobile phone i can send measurements of
the temperature of the area around me
but i have no idea if everybody will
never be interested on that and on the
other side querier might ask for one
particular type of data but don't know
if there is anybody who ever contributed
this data or so if the query will be
satisfied or not and who this anybody
will be okay so that was pretty much
what we said before why how can we have
participatory sensing going live so how
can go mainstream well the first things
user needs must be motivated to
participate and that's probably
something we are not very good to tell
because it's about a designing business
model to incentivize users to provide
their phone resources and participate to
this game one of the easiest things that
we could say is discounted data plan so
the more I provide data with my
smartphone the less i'll pay when i make
holes okay that's probably the easiest
way to go but there are lots of people
discussing on which is actually the
economic models that would fit in this
new computing parody but what we're
looking at is the privacy problem here
if users feel that their privacy is
endangered they will not agree to
participate and if you don't get a
critical mass of users providing data to
the system participatory center
adjustment doesn't make sense so this is
really based on the fact that a large
number of users will provide their
phones to participate in the system if
this will happen participatory sensing
makes no sense and to make this happens
you want users to be guaranteed the
about a certain amount of privacy it's a
new computing parenting so it has not
been there's not there hasn't been a lot
of work on it there have been lots of
proposals their project applications for
example the ones about the shading
prices in offline market and there's
lots of you know there's also a lot of
surveys discussing about security and
privacy challenges in this model the
only work that we are actually aware of
about privacy was at Mobley's 2008 and
we were not very happy with it so that's
why we started looking at participatory
sensing what they do first of all they
only work with the system only works
with a Wi-Fi infrastructure okay so no
matter your phone has a 3G 4G connection
they assume a ubiquitous Wi-Fi
infrastructure that may not be the case
at least in my opinion I don't see it
coming why is this well because they
they afford anonymity using standard IP
mac address recycling techniques okay so
they basically are anonymous towards the
access point doing these campaigns and
on top of that they use k anonymity
through mixed networks to keep the
privacy of the users sending out data to
the system and to to have all this
working they have Betty three
independent and non colluding
anonymizing and it is that's a little
bit too much from our point of view so
these are pretty much the limitations
assuming a Wi-Fi infrastructure this is
the first point we were not happy with
so we want to go for 3G 4G network also
because the the system will work only if
for example with continuous sensing only
if the device is always able to provide
data and this is not the case if you're
relying on a Wi-Fi infrastructure so we
really need to go to 3g 4g broadband
connection and the also the problem with
mix networks
those are statistical methods that only
achieve k anonymity and in some
scenarios this may not be an option for
example to achieve can illimité you
might need to wait for reports to for
enough reports to come in before you can
send out stuff so you basically if you
need reports in real time that may not
be an options anyhow they are looking at
statistical methods to achieve privacy
so we want to look a provable security
that's where we are aiming at so that
was the contribution of this first work
about participatory sensing so we're
looking at the cryptographic treatment
of participatory sensing and define the
privacy of both the data consumers that
our users wearing for data soap waiting
for which is the temperature in
cambridge today and the data providing
data so mobile phones sending out the
readings of the temperatures in their
area today and we also provide an
initial installation based on IP okay so
which are the imported parties in our
architecture so first of all you got the
sensors that are installed though
smartphones and emit data reports that
may be with or without the involvement
the active involvement of the user does
really matter and then we have carriers
okay so those are people carrying the
smartphones sensors might be embedded in
vehicles can we can be even carried by
animals but i'm not sure if cows are
interested in their privacy but I mean
anything can be together for us they are
mobile nodes okay so for example Markel
phones it's a mobile node okay on the
other side we have queries those are
user or application that subscribe to
specific information the temperature in
Cambridge so every day I get to know I
would like to get to know which is the
temperature in Cambridge and I want it
to pop up on my desktop on top of that
you have a network operator that
basically manages and provides access to
the network's that's for example
t-mobile
a service provider that is intermediary
the broker between users providing data
and Aquarius asking for data okay as of
now this is the required parties for
unknown private participatory sensing
application okay so if you go for
participatory signs yet you forget about
privacy that's at least what you need on
top of that when it comes to security we
also have a registration authority that
would be a phone manufacturer or any
other stakeholder in the system that
basically handles the registration of
participatory parties so this is the
only other entity that we introduced in
the system and this is pretty much the
architecture okay so here we have the
producers there are the mobile nodes
they first register to the registration
authority so here basically they
download the software to participate to
enter the application on the other side
of the system you have quitters as well
they need to register then it's about to
get authorized to receive one particular
type of measurements for example once
again temperature in Cambridge and if I
want out I need to register to the
registration authority once I am
registered to the registration authority
I get a token that I provide to the
service provider this is the broker ok
this is the intermediate between did a
consumer cell data users so registered
mobile nodes omit the reports through
the network operator to the service
provider the service providers does the
math so it checks which reports are of
interest to which queries and forward
those reports to the cleaners ok so that
this is pretty much it so if I'm there
I'm looking for temperature in Cambridge
I'm only going to get reports that are
tagged with temperature and Cambridge
privacy requirements first of all we
want the solution to be solved we are
not looking at false positive false
negatives so there are lots of so there
are lots of work about outsources
database practicing outsourced database
that achieve privacy
providing providing a set of answers
that include the answers that actually
satisfy the query and this is to protect
privacy we don't want we don't go into
we don't not want to go there we just
want a solution that provides me the
right answers I don't want full positive
first negatives i also want query
privacy so i want to protect my interest
I don't want anybody to know on what
data I am quitting I mean I don't want
anybody to know that I'm interesting The
Temper inner here I don't want anybody
to know that I'm interested in the price
of some drugs that I'm looking for okay
on the other side you also want no
privacy so whenever I send out a report
from my mobile nodes I only want
authorized queries that are looking for
that data to know what is that data
about and nothing else okay so which is
the intuition sorry of course we need to
hide reports and queries if we won't
read privacy of both data producers and
data consumers we need to hide reports
and queries so they need to be encrypted
and somehow the service provider needs
to do the matching blindly so again the
same if you are providing data about
temperature in Cambridge and I'm looking
for the same data so with data with the
same tag this matching has to be done
blindly by the service provider the next
solutions of course using pairwise key
between queries and mobile nodes or
public encryption but both solution do
not work in this case because as I said
one of the particular features of the
system is that users data consumers and
that producers do not do not have mutual
knowledge so they don't know of each
other they might be nobody interesting
the data that i provide of there might
be nobody that is actually providing
data that I'm interested in so here's
the main tuitions we can use I I be
based cryptography so probably we're
going to use the bonnie franklin
instantiation we treat queried NT fires
like identities of an IP scheme okay so
temperature in madrid is actually
identifier is actually an identity in
the IBD scheme so we encrypt our report
under data entry and once this is done
we don't need to find a way to provide
authorized it queries with the
corresponding decryption key okay so
here is really the baseline of the paper
using quantifiers as identity and
providing the corresponding zip shangri
to authorized users so how it works
right pretty pretty much with this vania
so this is done offline so the setup is
executed by the registration authority
and its basic the setup of an an IP
scheme there is a bilinear map and there
bunch of hash functions and then we go
online okay so here I the involved
parties the registration authority
mobile nodes providing data Twitter
asking for data and service provider
doing the matching in the middle so
those are the public parameters and
those are secrets s NC so at
registration time so the mobile nodes
needs to be authorized to provide
information to the season to provide
data reports to the system so
legislation type the mobile not just get
Z so here you can do you can do it in a
fancy way so you can anonymize the
mobile nodes or you might do something
not to have the registration authority
learning for which kind of reports the
mobile nodes wants to participate but it
really depends then on the business
model because probably if that guy is
going to get discounts for what he's for
the data he's providing to the system
may be really want to know who that is
and things like that also the querier
need to register a need to register to
get one particular to up of an upload
quick to the service provider queries of
one particular type so this is the ID of
the query for example temperature in
Cambridge what they get is basically a
signature on the ID and actually you can
do this blindly so the registration
alternative doesn't learn which is the
query that the query is interested in
once this is done now we really go
online okay so you have V on website and
you have the signature on one particular
type of query on this other side so now
the query has to offload the running
query to the service provider this run
inquiry is called all continuous query
as we want to call it it's called like
that because you just send it out once
and you get back data anytime that is
interesting data that is the data
satisfies your query so it's not like in
a database where you just issued worry
once and you get back once the results
here you offload the query the query
stands out there and whenever there is
interesting that the service provider
this data gets back to you so this
running query is basically this time to
start that it's a hash of a bilinear
pairing of a bilinear map Oh with the
art that is one public parameter well
the Z is embedded zis angelic side and a
signature here that is the signature of
the registration authority given to the
query about that particular kind of
query temperature in Cambridge so now
the sorry price is steep let's look at
what happens at the mobile nodes now the
mobile nodes needs to provide reports ok
so what we will provide is a pair T CT
we're basically city is the encryption
under this is a let's say a symmetric
reply with a yes for example under key K
of the data report okay and this key is
derived somehow by the
natural of the query so here is
temperature in Cambridge and here is 23
for example okay and the time that they
will be used to identify this kind of
data it's actually pretty much the same
thing here but with the different hash
functions so you will provide to this
pair T and city where this is a header
whether there is an encrypted tag and
this is the payload and we'll give it
back to the service provider the
seller-provided only needs to do
matching between the tags sent by the
mobile nodes and the tag offloaded by
the query if they match the pair is
forwarded back to the query and the
query just needs to compute the same key
he can do that because he has a
signature on the same ID that defines
the nature of the data item and want to
get the key you can do the decryption
using AES again okay so that's how it
works and why it is correct privacy okay
so two things not privacy and query
privacy about not privacy only
alternated where's that possess a valid
signature obtain information about this
pair they can actually decrypt that pair
okay in the paper there is a personal
game it's based on the CPI security of
the Bonnie Franklin I be skins and
pretty much the query plan as it works
the same way that is no one in this
paper in England the paper actually that
is except the array so the array is
actually allowed to learn information
about query interest is that is the ID
that it sent from the queries to the
registration authority in during the
registration by you can actually doing
blindly so you have nobody to learn what
you are quoting the system for and again
it's all reduced to the CPI security I
be since we are looking at mobile phones
we also took a little bit I look at
performance evaluations so we
implemented the operations that are
supposed to be carried out on the mobile
phones on some nokia and
those are the specifics about CPU and
RAM and actually the only thing that
mobile nodes need to do so the overhead
of the privacy protecting layer is the
production of T CD and that takes really
a little time it's not every ms on
average so we are not taking into
account the energy required to sense the
environment because this is actually
what the device should do anyway in a
non private participatory sensing
solution and actually they're very
little or no overhead at all at the
other parties because the service
provider only to mash hash values ok so
there are there are tags that are hashes
of something and they if they match the
service provider has to do the
forwarding and this is exactly what the
service provider has to do in an own
private participatory sent in solution
and as a negligible overhead for queers
because they only have to perform a es
or any symmetric key decryption
algorithm so what we are looking here
it's something that doesn't really cost
that much and adds some privacy to the
system few of the problems of course
well the quad privacy with respect to
the registration authority that's
already set so you can use blind ibe not
to have the registration authority
learning what York waiting for in the
system so if you're looking for
particular drugs we don't want anybody
not even the registration authority to
know that you want to have final grade
authorizations so for example you can
have the temperature in Cambridge only
if you're allowed to query for the
temperature in Cambridgeshire in the UK
so that's something that you can do
using hierarchical or attribute-based ib
and then that's probably the most
challenging part what if you want to
work on aggregates you want to get the
average temperature other functions some
mean but you also might need to get
predicates for example I do want the
average temperature today in Cambridge
but only if it's about 20 degrees and
this is probably where we need to go
because if it's true that there are so
many people if these things strikes out
and there are so many people providing
measurements you don't want all the
measurements on your phone they're going
to exhaust your battery so you really
want the service provider to do the math
and get to you only the relevant
information you might not really want
all the data that actually the system is
producing and of course Peter one is
going to be to have some paper nice
called coke we are looking on the
acronym so this is pretty much it there
are more information at this website so
thanks everyone and i'll be happy to ask
wayne to answer questions provider will
never write yes because otherwise the
service provider would be able to get
executed signatures right for x / n be
able to you that's correct match that's
correct yes the registration already
trusted here we're looking at a scenario
where the service provider but it's not
trust and i think this is knit all right
yes was just from the rafting you'll be
able to write we have to to put trust
and work yes terms of the business model
to go to see that there is going to be a
configuration where these two entities
are going to be separate because my
understanding is that company would
launch a service like this if they
actually have folks the registration
authority and the service yeah that
letter the thyroid good point actually
and another thing perhaps a bit related
i have i have a feeling thats
participatory sensing is happening in a
way but mostly by offering a different
service and having the data as a
by-product for example foursquare is
giving a different service to people but
the company collects information that
could be carried to extract other things
same thing with mobile flickr
applications I mean they're offering a
different service now the things that
don't you ever think that privacy is
actually going to be related mostly to
the service that is given to the user
and not the curing of the data so if we
take flickr for example you can upload
photographs and the price is mostly
related to the fact that somebody holds
your photographs now flickr can also
other people to clearly their database
and you can find information photos from
particular location so in a wait but
this battery sensing surveys but it's
that's a byproduct so I'm just wondering
what's your yes agree with I agree with
what you say might be difficult to have
some parties that is trusted and that is
not somehow related and service provider
because actually now that the models
that are out there I have everything
embedded in one single entity but it
seems that it would be as we said is
it's inevitable there would be no
solution if we go for that model can you
show a bit more about how to balance
between producers and consumers it seems
that if the average pupil users and
everyone interested in the same or
similar qualities then it should be
really hard not to think the full
information but what has been the
protein ah i'm trying i'm not sure that
i believe there is like 2 people who are
reporting temperature on your page and
the rest of the world is clearly your
bottom that's for that arguing how much
DX hackett so and as a fast and i can
see there is no way to automatically
balance of check that is not too much
information being excited after bin
optimized especially if you blind the
request to the trustee up that you don't
know how much data is being excited well
not if you don't right i mean you're a
I forgot you a question you are
going towards pretty much the scanner
limiting
KTVT that I modeling right I think if
you don't get a critical mass can you
manage then they will be in balance
which you know many two players on how
many consumers lateral motion there is
not a robot to have a gown yes yeah I've
actually one of the key point is having
user participating if users number if
you don't have enough user a critical
mass of users participating you the
whole system that doesn't make sense